hi I'm Eric Voss and this is a breakdown
of the walking dead season 7 episode 13
bury me here and the march to war with
the Savior's continues with the latest
casualty to be consumed by this ravenous
world
Jerry's cobbler leave the cobbler brood
also the not that surprising deaths of
Kingdom earth Benjamin and Richard as
Carol Morgan and Ezekiel finally get on
board I really love this episode it was
layered deep with hidden meaning and
metaphor and connections to other
episodes so I'm going to break it all
down starting with the opening images
the episode opens with this ominous
prologue scene of the kingdom errs
loading a single cantaloupe in the back
of a truck now if you think about this
first this is all obviously setting up
the mystery of who will die this episode
notice how they're all looking sadly at
this blood-stained and if you take
attendance of everyone we see really the
only Kingdom ER who goes on these
drop-offs who's missing is Benjamin and
of course we learn how that cantaloupe
plays into this later I also like the
framing of the shot the point of view
from inside the truck bed remember the
first time we saw the truck used Richard
was using it to herd pigs for the
savior's Richard fed the pigs Walker
meat as a kind of hopeful short-term war
tactic against negan
so this POV shot for shadows what
Richard tries to do with Benjamin this
episode use him as a pig for the
slaughter ultimately as a tactic to
trigger a war with the Savior's okay
moving on past the credits to Carol now
why is she crying in her sleep she later
asked Morgan why Jesus brought Daryl and
the rest of the kingdom because Daryl's
lied to her that Rick beat the Savior's
and arranged a deal isn't really adding
up like she knows that if Rick came to
the kingdom something must have been
wrong and that doubt is keeping her up
at night and then we see Morgan training
Henry that's the little brother to
Benjamin and this scene reminds us that
Benjamin has family to leave behind but
also someone to follow in his footsteps
and then check out this moment if you
see Dan right nothing changed
so this lesson goes deeper than just
maintaining your balance that's use a
votes app this has been Morgan's whole
life philosophy ever since leading
Eastman in season six like no matter
where your upper body or head is facing
your feet need to be rooted in the right
direction keeping you sane or in
Morgan's case keeping his mind clear now
for Morgan that direction has always
been to avoid all-out war but as we'll
see this episode that direction will
change when Morgan loses his footing and
I love how this episode applies this
concept of shifting directions with
Carol - as she uses this one-way sign to
take down walkers so rather than
following the one-way arrow is like a
street sign
she repurposes it as a weapon and
changes the direction of the arrow
essentially changing her own direction
from passive non-participant back to
active warrior now after Morgan refuses
to tell Carol the truth
notice how Carol refuses to teach
Benjamin obviously Carol doesn't want
any more blood on her hand since her
last attempts to teach kids didn't go so
well
but there's some irony here because when
you think about it by leaving Benjamin
behind and letting them go on the
drop-off Carole is kind of indirectly
responsible for his death
yeah switching your drop so really no
matter what Carole does she can't save
everyone from harm I also like how the
next scene lays out a ton of miscible
clues that Richard is behind the later
event we see that the Walker Carole left
behind earlier has now been killed and
then when Richard digs the open grave
there's a row of shopping carts and the
yellow bin that he'll used to block the
road and hide the missing cantaloupe and
we saw this Cady backpack back in
episode 10 Cady is the name of Richards
daughter and this backpack is really all
he has to remember her by in fact
Richard tells us later on that he lost
Katie while living in a camp that was
totally insecure but because he didn't
speak up and be part of the solution he
ended up losing everything I could do
and that really explains why he's been
so outspoken now in the kingdom okay
moving on to Ezekiel and this new
kingdom er Nabila who seems to be a
farmer or gardener for Ezekiel but also
a kind of spiritual advisor here's the
beautiful thing you imagine you can tear
it out and cut it down you can burn it
and throw it all the way but if you want
it can all grow back so in many ways
this episode is making the kingdom
parallel Alexandria with Ezekiel
suffering the same kind of tragedy from
the saviors that Rick did at the
beginning of season 7 also it's
interesting how the current members of
this community reflect Rick's community
before negan like Nabila who's a
faithful Muslim is the counterpart to
Gabriel the Episcopal priest
Benjamin is the idealistic doomed young
lover kind of like Glenn and Richard is
the Haunted soldier trying to move on
from losing his family like Abraham and
Jerry well there's only one Jerry and in
this scene Nabila is telling Ezekiel
that we've old which is a type of Beetle
that destroys crops have infested His
Royal Garden and it needs to be uprooted
and burned remember in my breakdown of
episode 2 I talked about how Ezekiel
sees his garden as kind of a Garden of
Eden a lush utopia where he can live out
his fantasy safe from the outside world
but now Ezekiel has a fly in the
ointment or a weevil in his garden
symbolizing his realization that it's
impossible for him to keep up this
facade eventually reality is going to
creep in in the shape of weevils and
just like giving up his precious private
garden to save all of the kingdom's
crops Ezekiel is going to have to
sacrifice what he holds dear to save the
whole kingdom and real quick as the
wheelbarrow grows off with the
cantaloupe this shot makes sure to give
us a clear look at the count this sets
up the miscount that will become
important later on okay moving on to
Benjamin giving Morgan this painting if
you look closely this is a matador
fighting a bull perhaps as a symbol of
what Morgan does fight more fierce
opponents by tricking them into losing
their balance and their tempers kind of
like a matador does but there's also a
graffiti cross over it this could be
foreshadowing the fact that Morgan is
about to leave his style of fighting
behind him and take a more aggressive
approach like the guys who end up
slaughtering the bullets he ends the
fight alright moving on to this
roadblock and at first this seems like
another parallel to Rick and its people
right before their conflicts with the
saviors last season remember the
Savior's use several roadblocks to box
Rick and his people in but of course
this is the route notice how Richard
hangs back and when he appears in the
next shot that yellow bin is behind them
that's why we see the shot later when
Morgan makes the realization that
Richard is behind them and this shopping
cart arrow points to this open grave
marked with the title of the episode
bury me here
Ezekiel explains how this is an act of
madness one man going insane in the
world with so much darkness people that
live through every kind of misery
tyrants genocide systems of quiet hate
on others enjoy freedom on the same
piece of land
if this how we left exist now is luck we
are not all insane and notice how the
camera cuts back to Morgan for this line
and I think this handwritten sign and
the idea of madness is meant to call
back these season 3 episode clear which
was the episode that reintroduced Morgan
to the series remember he was wallowing
in a similar madness with a ton of
unsettling handwritten messages after
losing his sons wing I actually think
this season hinted at this upcoming
callback with the recent reference to
Michonne
cat statue which happened in that same
episode in season 3 so along with that
episode and the episode with Eastman in
season 6 this episode marks another
pivotal turning point for Morgan and
fittingly this scene uses the image of
an arrow to signify this shifting
direction for the character okay moving
on to this standoff with the savior
group so Gavin takes their guns because
the cantaloupe count is short eleven
instead of twelve
now why twelve cantaloupes exactly now I
know maybe a stretch but I think that
the number twelve was specifically
chosen to reflect the twelve disciples
of Jesus I know
another religious analogy but shut up
it's been a while so at the Last Supper
Jesus was surrounded by his twelve
disciples but he knew one of them was
planning to betray him Judas and I think
this is meant to correspond to Richard
the disciple who betrays his king by
stealing this Judas cantaloupe and just
to clarify what Richard plan was here
remember back in episode 10 after
Richard proposed to use Carol as bait to
trigger a war with the Savior's it ended
with this exchange with Daryl
it's actually Kingdom why don't you so
ever since that moment Richard took
Darrell's advice
remembering that Gavin promised he would
be the next to die if anything went
wrong in the future
so Richard prepared to sacrifice himself
to push a see keel into war he made
peace with Morgan he sabotaged the drop
by delaying them and stealing the can
alone and he dug his own grave dying for
the kingdom here we come unfortunately
this doesn't go the way Richard expect
when Gavin orders this execution
notice how the editing matches the negan
line up at the beginning of the season
cutting to each character space as they
brace themselves for the worst this is
the kingdom's day of reckoning but since
this rat-faced
pricks Jared models himself on negan he
too takes enjoyment on making his sadism
unpredictable so like how negan killed
Glenn seemingly at random
Jared shoots Benjamin instead of Richard
and ultimately just like Alexandria the
kingdom will lose both their idealistic
young lover and their heartbroken
soldier and the parallels between
Richard and Glenn continue in the next
shot with Carol planting tomato seeds in
her garden I think this is a callback to
a scene last season when Glenn reassured
Maggie that the tomato plants would grow
the idea being that life is still
possible in this world even if Glenn
would never get to see that life bear
fruit I don't know and then notice now
as the truck pulls up Carol faces these
dark storm clouds now storm clouds are
pretty much archetypal symbols for a
coming war and these clouds are bringing
the death of a martyr that will further
trigger the war for Carol and to drive
this point home listen to Benjamin's
last words now on the surface Benjamin
is just echoing the Morgan that
philosophy of their martial arts but
it's also foreshadowing what's to come
when Jared and the Savior's injured
their opponents Benjamin really they've
injured themselves because now war is
inevitable also when Carol tries
unsuccessfully to stop the bleeding
I like how this delivers on the warning
that Richard gave her back in episode 8
when they turned on us and they will
step clauses could have be on your hands
and it's not just Carol's hands later
after a Benjamin decide
notice how there's a second head wound
from where he was stabbed to keep him
from turning and Morgan claims his blade
implying he was one who had to do it
making the blood on his hands as well
and when Morgan relapses notice the
rapid editing and inserts of the various
handwritten signs and images of his son
Duane and his wife Jenny this is meant
to show Morgan is falling back into his
despair from the clear episodes actor
Lennie James called it wilderness Morgan
for Morgan this is history repeating
himself in the past he couldn't bring
himself to shoot his Walker turned white
so he let his son die and now he feels
responsible for the deaths of the
closest thing he's had to a son since
Benjamin which is why later
Morgan accidentally says
Dwain when he's talking about Benjen I
know he to choose and then slogged when
had to die
Dwayne Benjamin Benjamin so after
confronting Richard and learning of
Richards plan to use this tragedy it's
interesting when Morgan snaps and kills
Richard and he repeats to Gavin what
Richard said to him we get it we
understand what we need to do I want to
show you that we get it do we understand
what it is that we need to do for Morgan
killing Richard solves both of his
problems in a way he hates Richard for
causing Benjamin to die but he doesn't
want Benjamin to die in vain either so
he killed Richard and then basically
becomes him carrying out Richard's plan
and in a sense he allows Richard to have
his victory too because now the kingdom
is on a warpath with the savior thinking
they can trust them but of course it
also creates a new problem for Morgan
because by killing the human being he
has compromised the path of peace that
he's been on shifting into a new
direction and real quick I like how the
three blood marks on Morgan States
correspond to the three innocents whose
blood still weigh on him his wife Jenny
his sons Wayne and now his surrogate son
Benjamin moving on after Morgan buries
Richard and takes down walkers he
returns to Carroll and the blood sprayed
on his face and neck parallels the way
Carol came to him at the beginning of
the episode reflecting his changed
mindset to parallel the direction Tara
was going in and after Carole learns the
truth about negan Glenn and Abraham for
response to Morgan's warpath is the same
thing that is v fuel told her back in
episode two like maybe you could go and
not go you didn't go and not go so by
that she means Morgan has the option to
seclude himself and then he'll
emotionally kind of like she did but
still not go completely off the deep end
so they switched places with Morgan in
the cottage now and Carol back in the
kingdom and in the next scene
Carol reunites with Ezekiel as they
plant the first plant in the royal
garden after they had to uproot and burn
everything from the weevil and here we
see nabila's metaphor making sense yes
Ezekiel had to give up something
important to him his garden and also
Benjamin but he gained
something from this sacrifice as well
the crops from the rest of the kingdom
are saved and you can always grow a new
garden to replace what he lost
and by planting this new tree with the
little brother Henry shows that not all
is lost with Benjamin's family either
meanwhile the closing images are less
optimistic crazy old man Morgan sits
alone on his doorstep
sharpening his bo staff to repurpose it
into a spear much like how Carroll used
the one-way sign as a spear his
nonviolent mindset no longer serves him
and his direction has shifted behind him
the axe is wedged into firewood
symbolizing the killing is necessary
philosophy of Ric creeping up behind
Morgan and then notice how Morgan
suddenly turned maybe hallucinating
something his mind is clearly slipping
away from him although that grave was
dug for Richard the madness of it has
infected Morgan too as he returns to the
days of clear waiting to be buried right
here ok looking ahead to next episode
episode 14 titled the other side it
looks like we'll be back with Rosita and
Sasha as they team up to kiss this war
finally started the sneak peak scene
shows Sasha leaving Enid behind while
Enid gives her a 10-minute head start
before she tells Maggie and the promo
shows the Savior's arriving at the
hilltop while Maggie rushes to hi Daryl
and an interesting shot of Sasha with
negan in her crosshairs of course we
still have three more episodes and
everyone on the show from Rick to
Ezekiel have assured us that the war can
wait another day so I wouldn't get my
hopes up for any first shot just yet and
some lingering questions one do you
think it was right for Morgan to kill
Richard I mean the guy didn't mean to
cause Benjamin's death and since both
paths lead to war anyway I kind of feel
like keeping Richard around as a strong
warrior and avoiding a relapse into
another moral crisis might have been a
smarter move for Morgan and to kind of a
broader question who do you think is the
strongest leader in all these
communities now according to the show
the answer seems to be Rick obviously
but Ezekiel's got the most creative
method of ruling for sure
personally I used to be negan ran the
tightest ship at the sanctuary but now
it seems like he's inspiring some rogue
at Hillary from his subjects which are
causing problems in his empire and even
though she isn't technically the leader
yet
kind of things that we're going to start
seeing some more effective leadership
from Maggie at the hilltop anyway let me
know what you think in the comment ok
thanks for watching and make sure to
check out all my other breakdown from
the season 7 episode and if you like
this video please hit like and subscribe
to new rock stars also please share this
video and if you really like new rock
stars you can contribute to us on
patreon thank you so much to all of our
current patrons you guys are the best
especially Kenny Smith you can hit me up
on Twitter a da vas with any thoughts or
theories that you have on The Walking
Dead or follow new rockstars on Twitter
at new rockstars for updates on our
videos ok thanks for watching bye